hello and welcome today i wanted to share
with you what in my opinion is the single
most useful decorator in python taking a look at
the code that's already written here first we have
a function which computes the nth fibonacci
number and it does so in a recursive fashion
so it's extremely inefficient next in
our main function we have just a loop
going through 400 numbers just printing
out the number and the ith fibonacci number
and then at the end we print done now if i
were to actually run this code you would see
that while the first few go very quickly it starts
grinding to a halt around 31 32 33 and essentially
each number after that takes twice as long as
the number before it and this is because of the
you know bad implementation of the
fibonacci function that we've given here
the main problem with this implementation
is that when i compute fib of n minus 1 well
part of that computation is to compute
fib of n minus 2. so i'm doing a lot of
repeated work here every level down i'm going
to be repeating work that has already been done
and then just was thrown away in a different
function call an easy way to fix this is just by
remembering values that have already been computed
and that's what the decorator does so my favorite
decorator in python is the cache decorator from
the functools library so functools is a built-in
so you don't have to install anything and
then you just hit your fibonacci function
with cache and now let's go
ahead and try running it again
you see it goes through all 400 of them
immediately and the reason for that was
that even though we have this very inefficient
definition what cache does is it just remembers
all of the values of the function that it's
computed before so if you compute fib of 398
then when i compute fib of 399 it looks up fib of
398 and 397 and it says oh i've already computed
both of those things instead of recomputing
them using this recursive definition it will
just use the value that it's remembered from
the previous time that you've run the function
so i find this to be extremely useful because
it allows you to avoid repeated computations
there's also a variant of cache called lru
cache lru stands for least recently used
and it does essentially the same thing but
instead of storing all previous values of
the function that you've called it with it only
stores a certain number of them so let's just
replace this with an lru cache and give it a
max size of say five this means that it's just
going to store the five most recent values of
the function that i've called now if i'm just
running up values of the function in a for loop
like this then that's plenty just to do this
so still if i run the function it completes just
as fast as before and this way i'm only using a
little bit more memory but it's a huge speed
up compared to when there was no cache at all
so i found myself using cache or lru cache
in a lot of different projects just anywhere
where i can see myself accidentally repeating
computations that might take a long time that's
a great place to just throw it in a cache or an
lru cache you don't have to do any other work
and it can provide a lot of speed up
if you know the right place to use it